[Musica]
comporre Scomporre il denaro con porre
scomporre la ricchezza
molto spesso quando si parla di soldi
non so se anche voi avete sentito un
fastidio quando sono c'è stato a 40
milioni di dollari molto spesso
soprattutto perché siamo italiani siamo
poco abituati a parlare di soldi di
denaro di ricchezza però provate a
pensare L'unica cosa che ha veramente un
impatto ogni singolo giorno su tutte le
aree della nostra vita è proprio il
denaro Siete riusciti a salire qua
grazie al denaro Siete presenti al The
Dex grazie al denaro la nostra salute
dipende dalla nostra capacità di
produrre denaro in parte la nostra
capacità di creare emozioni
deriva dal denaro perché un conto è
stare in alcuni posti belli come questo
e un altro fare le stesse cose magari
imposti meno modelli e quindi ogni area
della nostra vita Dove vanno i nostri
figli a scuola La nostra istruzione la
nostra capacità di viaggiare di essere
liberi e quindi bisogna dedicare al
denaro lo stesso rispetto a cui
dedichiamo magari in altre aree della
nostra vita e purtroppo per come
nasciamo nessuno ci ha insegnato cose
sul denaro Quindi l'obiettivo di questi
minuti è quello di cercare di comporre e
scomporre la ricchezza grazie al fatto
che ho avuto la possibilità di stare
insieme
ad alcune delle persone più famose anche
più ricche che ci sono nel mondo ho
avuto la possibilità di capire qual era
il mindset Innanzitutto una precisazione
l'80% dei milionari sono di prima
generazione non li hanno ereditati non
li hanno vinti
si pensa che non l'abbiano fatti in modo
disonesto ma sono le hanno creati loro
e quindi c'è solo un 20% di persone che
ereditano e questi numeri sono aumentati
soprattutto con le nuove tecnologie Ve
lo ricordate una volta si diventava
ricca ricchi se avevamo tanti schiavi
poi si è passato alla se avevamo eravamo
ricchi se avevamo tanti operai quindi
avevamo la fabbrica poi diventavamo
ricchi se studiavamo a scuola quindi
l'essere un professore l'essere un
medico era una cosa importante poi a
quel c'è stato un periodo in cui si
diventava ricchi per strada quelli che
vengono chiamati streetsmart cioè le
persone che vedono le opportunità e tra
gli anni sessanta gli anni 80/90 mancava
tutto nell'Italia che che bisognerà
costruire le lavatrici bisognava ogni
cosa che si apriva in qualche modo aveva
successo Perché la domanda era molto
forte e poi si è passati la ricchezza si
è trasferita a quella che viene chiamata
Silicon Smart cioè le persone che
facevano software up la new Economy ha
trasformato un sacco di persone ricche e
adesso stiamo entrando in una nuova
epoca che è quella dell'intelligenza
artificiale e credo che tantissimi nuovi
ricchi Alcuni lo sono già diventati
vengono o verranno da questo nuovo mondo
Quindi quali sono le cose che impattano
sul denaro la parte più importante che
ho visto in tutti da la possibilità di
stare con Richard Branson con Donald
Trump con personaggi che magari sono
sconosciuti a voi ma sono super famosi
nei loro nelle loro micro nicchie è la
prima cosa è che loro non hanno sogni
non hanno desideri hanno obiettivi cioè
sono persone che non desiderano ma
dicono Ok devo fare questa cosa Come
faccio a farla accadere e un'altra
caratteristica particolare
è che loro non fanno azioni normali
fanno azioni massicce e continuative E
fino a che non ottengono risultato non
mollano quindi ecco la prima cosa è
proprio l'impatto sul mindset la nostra
felicità la nostra infelicità la
capacità di fare denaro o la non
capacità di fare denaro deriva prima
dalla testa ma la cosa prima che ho
visto è che queste persone hanno proprio
la visione vogliono creare un mondo
migliore vogliono impattare non su 50 su
100 ma vogliono impattare su milioni di
persone quindi la capacità di impattare
su tantissime persone poi è quello che
in un secondo momento si trasforma in
una grossa ricchezza economica l'altra
cosa
che caratteristica che caratterizza le
persone che ottengono risultati con il
denaro è lo slegamento del concetto
tempo per soldi se ci pensate siamo
cresciuti e la scuola come come è
strutturata il fatto anche solo di
pensare che abbiamo ancora la campanella
a scuola che determina il passaggio tra
un compito e l'altro è la stessa cosa
che succedeva nell'epoca industriale Se
pensate alle scuole del 1700 e il 1800 e
riguardate le scuole di oggi sono molto
simili il processo di apprendimento
nella scuola non è cambiato e
Bisognerebbe impattare magari insegnare
ai bambini come essere felici insegnare
la gestione delle emozioni e insegnare
anche come funziona il denaro e quindi
molto spesso rimaniamo intrappolati
nella nella cosa tempo per soldi quindi
non solo le persone che hanno tenuto
grandi risultati finanziari hanno
slegato questo concetto l'anno scomposto
e sono riusciti ad avere un impatto
creando valore quindi la prima loro
domanda la prima loro ossessione è come
posso portare valore a magari milioni di
persone a centinaia di milioni di
persone come posso creare una ricchezza
che va da ben oltre me stesso ma possa
durare in qualche modo per generazioni
avete sentito un paio di parole Una è
ossessione che nella in italiano suona
Non suona benissimo Però sul denaro Se
voi ci pensate e guardate o ascoltate le
storie delle persone da cui si può poi
dedurre un mindset l'ossessione non è
proprio una cosa negativa è che io mi
sveglio al mattino con una carica
energetica perché voglio creare quella
cosa voglio impattare sul mondo Voglio
fare in modo che queste altre persone io
posso cambiare la vita di quelle persone
e quindi un po' così come la mia
ossessione è quella di cercare di
impattare sul mondo cambiando
l'educazione finanziaria o in qualche
modo dando educazione finanziaria perché
credo che questo sia uno dei modi per
avere un mondo migliore perché non c'è
cosa più brutta di dover continuare a
pensare al denaro
Il denaro è un asset va creato e quindi
anche qua arriviamo a una nuova parola
No asset verso tempo le persone ricche
si concentrano sulla creazione di un
asset un qualcosa che poi
mi generi in automatico il denaro Quindi
cosa vuol dire essere ricchi non vuol
dire avere un milione 10 milioni 50
milioni vuol dire avere abbastanza
Entrate
automatiche cioè soldi
slegati dal tempo quindi chiaramente 15
minuti non sono sufficienti a
raccontarvi questa cosa ma Incominciate
a pensare Ok ma come faccio a slegare la
produzione del denaro dal mio tempo
e quando ho cominciato a farvi questa
domanda slegare il tempo dal denaro e
focalizzarvi sulla creazione di un asset
su una creazione di un qualcosa che ben
vi dirà denaro in automatico Questo è il
primo passo per comporre e scomporre la
ricchezza perché la generazione di un
asset che può essere Nel mio caso ad
esempio libri
corsi che possono essere venduti in
indirettamente senza di me anche
prendere dei comprare una casa e
metterla in affitto è il classico degli
asset italiani quindi Dovremo
incominciare a pensare di spostare il
focus da dedico più tempo a una cosa che
però Se smetto di farla Smetto anche di
produrre denaro a Come posso creare
qualcosa che continui a generare denaro
indipendentemente dal fatto che io passi
del tempo a farlo Quindi come dicevamo
può essere il tradi corpo può essere
l'immobiliare possono essere aziende
dove non lavoro avete sentito che ho più
di 30 aziende Io in questo momento sono
qua Mentre alcune delle mie aziende
stanno lavorando quindi come posso
creare
degli asset che funzionino senza di me è
una cosa possibile assolutamente
lo faccio ormai da vent'anni e Credo che
questa sia una delle cose più importanti
che dovremmo portarci via da oggi per
quanto riguarda denaro e Finanza quindi
incominciare a pensare al denaro non
come una risorsa scarsa ma come una
risorsa super abbondante e la domanda è
sono io la persona giusta o le
informazioni giuste o ho fatto il
passaggio giusto mentale poi per
generare questa ricchezza è chiaro che
dipende molto dal contesto da dove siete
nati Io sono nato da una famiglia umile
mio papà faceva il capostazione mia
mamma faceva la casalinga e davanti a me
c'era una famiglia ricca ora provate a
pensare a svegliarvi tutte le mattine e
a essere messi a confronto con la
ricchezza io andavo al mercato a
comprare le scarpe e loro invece
andavano nel negozio fighetto perché è
un bambino di 6 7 8 10 12 anni deve
vivere tutta questa differenza Questo
impatto che in qualche modo poi mi ha
permesso di essere un propulsore per
cercare di capire che Ma qual è la
differenza tra le persone ricche povere
e la classe media Beh se devo dare un
riassunto sta esclusivamente nella testa
quindi il mio mindset è quello che poi
mi fa fare le azioni e le azioni sono le
cose che mi portano poi ai risultati se
i risultati al punto di vista
finanziario non mi piacciono
e devo cambiare la mia azioni e se non
riesco a cambiarle vuol dire che c'è
qualcosa nella mia testa tra le mie
orecchie che non mi permette di farlo e
una volta che capisco che il denaro È
solo un gioco mentale e ha delle regole
delle regole precise
staccare il tempo dal denaro creare
asset non avere desideri ma avere degli
obiettivi avere una visione su dove si
vuole andare trasformare questi
obiettivi in un qualcosa di temporale e
continuare a lavorarci in modo
ossessionato giorno per giorno finché
non si ottiene il risultato credo che
questo sia una delle tante lezioni che
ho imparato da queste persone che hanno
tenuto risultati straordinari dal punto
di vista finanziario Ecco c'è una cosa
importante noi non siamo in un mondo o o
faccio soldi o sono felice o faccio
soldi ho una bella famiglia o faccio No
Siamo in un mondo e e quindi
incominciamo a cambiarci le domande e a
capire come il nostro cervello ci può
indirizzare verso soluzioni diverse
perché la qualità della nostra vita
dipende dalla qualità delle domande che
ci facciamo domande di qualità
hanno un impatto sulla nostra vita e
sulla qualità della nostra vita quindi
quali sono le domande che ci facciamo
sui soldi cosa pensiamo del denaro cosa
pensava la nostra famiglia e come questa
cosa può cambiare e può diventare una
cosa
impattante per il nostro futuro
finanziario perché perché per guadagnare
una cifra che non avete mai guadagnato
dovete diventare delle persone che non
siete mai state Ve lo ripeto perché per
guadagnare una cifra che non avete mai
guadagnato dovete diventare delle
persone che non sono mai state
emozionalmente psicologicamente e anche
di conoscenze pratiche quanto impatta la
testa e quanto impatta la tecnica
Quando io ho incominciato questo
percorso sulla mia educazione
finanziaria e su che cosa vuol dire
Finanza personale Io volevo il segreto
Volevo il trucco volevo che qualcuno mi
spiegasse Che cosa dovevo fare
praticamente per ottenere il risultato
però la tecnica incide solo per il 20%.
dopo più di vent'anni che insegno queste
cose dopo più di 60-70 mila persone a
cui ho trasferito le mie informazioni
nei corsi mi sono reso conto che la
tecnica non è importante perché perché
la tecnica la insegno uguale a tutti ma
perché delle persone ottengono risultati
straordinari e altri non ne ottengono
semplicemente perché il denaro in gioco
mentale prima
riuscite ad avere un impatto su tutto
quello che non si vede quindi se vuoi
Guardate un albero
la parte più importante dell'albero non
sono i frutti Cioè non sono i risultati
finanziari la parte più importante
dell'albero sono le radici e se io
voglio cambiare i frutti non posso
tirare giù tutte le pere e sperare No
spero che vengano mele Spero che vengano
mele non funziona così devo cambiare le
radici e le radici è le radici sono il
modo con cui pensiamo il denaro come lo
componiamo E come lo scomponiamo quindi
credo che questo piccolo intervento
possa essere d'ispirazione e
incominciare ad approfondire la tematica
del denaro perché perché se non siete
ricchi e perché nessuno ve l'ha ancora
insegnato Quindi grazie per avermi
ospitato qua in questa meravigliosa
cornice Spero di avervi lasciato un
semino che poi possa crescere per la
vostra Libertà finanziaria Grazie buona
giornata